all right The Bachelorette just got
started and next week things get a
little nasty between the guys yo for
real okay I'm serious hey cool bro keep
that up you're gonna lose your damn keys
don't touch me dude I'm just saying in
real life if a guy rolled up on another
guy like that there would be some kind
of physicality right you're gonna go
after them there be some kind of
physicality little bit anyway Louie then
you always wonder how much is real and
how much is just for the cameras and you
always want to remember it's a TV show
and that is why I am truly addicted to
the scripted series unreal because they
show you things that if true the people
on reality dating shows do not want you
to know just QR [ __ ]
ladies welcome back to everlasting it's
a show bachelor host Chris Harrison
called really terrible but in just one
season unreal has earned a huge
following vet says otherwise well the
show really pull back the veil we see
how these reality shows for a little bit
manipulated and you watch reality shows
anymore and make it oh totally watch
them I'm still love them they're it's
definitely entertainment but you watch
it now seemed a little bit more of the
craft and the art work that goes into
putting them together why didn't you
should just put this entire thing in the
cut I mean at least to the barber she
calls her because the rest is a little
PBS don't let's explain unreal was
created by a former bachelor producer
the dark comedy stars shiri appleby as
well a conflicted producer on a bachelor
like TV series she'll do anything to
create drama for ratings and her boss
Quinn played by constance zimmer is even
more ruthless Shen tall are sad sack of
the Dead fiance oh and close up on hot
rachel and stop that's her name how much
of the reality TV fan were you before
you started watching unreal not at all I
could only watch one episode there was a
hot air balloon there was like a weird
like tantric massaging sex thing I was
like well I they did everything we did
on our show like how is this happening
expect more sexy scenes in season 2 what
is it like shooting those this time
we'll rehearse in the trailer before
hand in all of my years of sex scene
experience the real key is to just shoot
it as quickly as possible so we're does
it love little pregame session my
trailer ladies I urge you open your
hearts to your suitor Darius bet I love
the fact that we're finally getting an
african-american suitor I know something
that the bachelor has never done just
saying you said it I'm just saying I
don't know why I took so long but we're
telling that story and to help tell that
story ETonline TV editor Leanna Aguilera
was on set she has a pivotal role in the
premier playing what else a report rest
of the game
you're just getting amazing great job
I'm very proud of you actually upstage
both of us I'll kill DISA killing it
nicely done LeAnn